I BELIEVE IT WAS TO EXPIRE ON
MAY 15TH.
ALL THIS HAVE OCCURS AT A TIME
WHEN WE ARE REEXAMINING OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA, THE
SOURCE OF THE VIRUS AND WHETHER
IT WAS DELIBERATE OR
DELIBERATELY MISLEADING.
RIGHT NOW THE READ ON ALL THAT
HAVE WITH RETIRED BRIGADIER
GENERAL.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
YOU’VE HEARD THE STORIES AND
BACK AND FORTH, THEY RECENTLY--
THAT IS THE CHINESE UPPED THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS OUT OF WUHAN TO
A LITTLE OVER 3,000.
THE TOTAL DEATH COUNT IS
REMARKABLY LOW WHEN YOU CONSIDER
A LITTLE MORE THAN 8800 COMPARED
TO WHERE WE ARE, IT ISN’T AND
DOESN’T SEEM REALISTIC.
EVEN NOW, ARE YOU TRUSTING THE
NUMBERS YOU’RE GETTING OUT OF
CHINA?
>> I WOULD NOT TRUST ANYTHING
THAT COMES OUT OF CHINA RIGHT
NOW.
YOU KNOW, WHAT HAPPENED, IT’S
REALLY--
WHETHER IT WAS A DELIBERATE
MANUFACTURED VIRUS OR SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED, AN ACCIDENT IN
THE WUHAN TESTING CENTER THERE,
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
DELIBERATELY WITHHELD
INFORMATION, DELIBERATELY
MANIPULATED INFORMATION AND THE
NUMBERS YOU JUST ARTICULATED ARE
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
THEY SUPPRESSED WHISTLEBLOWERS
TALKING ABOUT HOW BAD THIS WAS
AND THE HUMAN-TO-HUMAN ASPECT OF
THIS.
AT CHINA SAID -- AND THE WHO WAS
A PUPPET FOR CHINA AND SAID THE
SAME THING AND SO, IT WAS A
DELIBERATE ACT OF MISINFORMATION
BY THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND IT
IS TAUNTAMOUNT TO DETONATING A
BOMB IN MY VIEW.
WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND I THINK
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM AND
GENERAL MILLEY AND HIS TEAM,
THEY’RE FOCUSED ON THE ACCURATE
INFORMATION SO WE CAN ASSESS AND
RESPOND.
OF COURSE THE PRIORITY RIGHT NOW
IS TO SAVE AMERICANS LIVES AND
THAT’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING.
NEIL: IF THE CHINESE DID DUPED
PEOPLE, THEY DUPED THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AS WELL WHO
SAID AS YOU KNOW, GENERAL, BACK
IN JANUARY THAT THEY WERE
WORKING HARD ON THIS, THAT THEY
WERE BEING VERY TRANSPARENT.
SO WAS HE FOOLED BY THEM AS
WELL?
>> NO, I DON’T THINK SO.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS, YOU
KNOW, INTELLIGENCE, YOU READ
INTELLIGENCE EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND MAKE THE BEST ASSESSMENTS
THAT YOU GET FROM THE FOLKS THAT
YOU HAVE IN-COUNTRY AND IN THE
REGION AND MAKE ASSESSMENTS.
THE ASSESSMENTS, THIS WAS NOT
HUME HUMAN-TO-HUMAN AND THE
PRESIDENT MADE A DECISION THAT
WAS UNPOPULAR TO SHUT DOWN
CHINA, BASED ON INSTINCT TO SHUT
DOWN TRAVEL AND THAT DIRECTLY
HAS SAVED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
LIVES FROM MY POINT OF VIEW.
AND THEN TO SHUT DOWN TRAVEL
FROM EUROPE.
AS WE GOT MORE CLARITY ON THE
INFORMATION ON WHAT I WOULD CALL
THE ENEMY SITUATION FROM MY
MILITARY DAYS, YOU GAIN A BETTER
PICTURE.
IT’S LIKE A MOVEMENT TO CONTACT
AS WE USE TODAY CALL IT AND YOU
GET MORE INFORMATION EVERY DAY
AS YOU GO, AS YOU GET FURTHER
INTO THE SITUATION, YOUR
INFORMATION CLARIFIES AND THEN
YOU HAVE BETTER AND BETTER
RESPONSES AND YOU’RE ABLE TO
OVERCOME IT AND THEN TAKE OVER
THE SITUATION AS THE PRESIDENT
HAS DONE WITH HIS TASK FORCE.
AND STANDING UP THAT TASK FORCE
AND DOING THE DAILY PRESS
BRIEFINGS, AND GETTING THE
ACCURATE INFORMATION OUT THERE
DESPITE, QUITE FRANKLY, WHAT THE
MUCH IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS
SIDED WITH CHINA ON THIS THING
INEXPLICABLY.
IT’S BECAUSE THE VIRUS AND THE
DAMAGE TO THE ECONOMY AND TO THE
HEALTH OF AMERICANS, YOU KNOW,
WORKS AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND
SO THE MEDIA WANTS THAT TO
HAPPEN MORE, TO FURTHER THAT
NARRATIVE, BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN VERY STRONG ON THIS IN MY
OPINION.
NEIL: BUT THERE IS STILL,
GENERAL, THERE’S STILL SOME
CULPABILITY.
IT’S EASY TO PLAY MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACK.
BUT IF PETER NAVARRO WAS WARNING
HIM, BUT IT’S NOT EXCLUSIVELY ON
CHINA AND THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION?
>> I WOULD SAY THIS IS
EXCLUSIVELY WITHIN THE REALM OF
CHINA AND CHINA LIES AND CHINA
MISINFORMATION.
WE SHOULD GIVE NO QUARTER, NEIL,
TO CHINA.
THERE SHOULD BE NOTHING SPARED.
THIS IS A COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP
THAT HID THE INFORMATION.
THEY SHOULD DOWN TRAVEL WITHIN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY, BUT THEY
ALLOWED THE VIRUS TO GO TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THEY INTENTIONALLY ALLOWED THIS
TO HAPPEN AND THEY SHUT DOWN THE
CENTERS, THEY SHUT DOWN THE
WHISTLEBLOWERS AND THEY SHUT
DOWN TRAVEL, AND THEY ALLOWED
IT, AND KILLED 150,000 PEOPLE.
NEIL: YOU RAISE AN ISSUE, IF WE
CAN’T TRUST THEM ON A MEDICAL,